que vous a préparé c'était super
[Musique]
non je crois pas parce que ne partirait
des républicains est très divisé et des
divisés entre ceux qui se sentent plus
proches du rassemblement national et
ceux qui sont attirés par pas la
république engage le parti
gouvernemental damon macro et donc que
cette union des droites elle me paraît
très problématique mulhouse pourquoi
c'est pas sa place c'est pas des
passants légaliste qui décède le patron
des policiers etc darmanin qui
manifestent contre lui contre darmana un
peu curieux pour les français
bon évidemment se pose est ce que cette
question d'un spectacle surréaliste qui
voit le ministre manifesté aux côtés de
ceux qui le dit
bien elle a ébranlé cette grande
révolution individualiste qui est prêt
d'essence en 1968 et l'esprit
communautaire réapparu à la faveur de
l'entrée de la solidarité qui s'est
manifestée du repli sur les familles
l'individu seul s'est senti beaucoup
plus fragiles qui ne s'était senti ces
dernières décennies
et je crois que cette pandémie pour
avoir pour effet de faire revenir un
goût une volonté d'une vie plus
communautaire plus solidaire et moins
individualiste non absolument pas j'ai
aucune raison de le regretter
j'ai fait ce que je pouvais y faire
c'est à dire essayer de servir mon pays
mais moi je ne vais pas penser comme les
autres j'étais un prestataire extérieur
que j'avais un métier m'engager pour ça
j'ai fait mon métier mais je les fais
aussi avec des idées qui bt propre et
parce que la stratégie que je portais
celle qui consistait à remettre en avant
l'identité nationale
[Musique]
oui j'ai une petite j'ai surtout une
idée de la manière dont ça a été tourné
contre moi parce que c'est absolument
indigne et toute façon je devais être
coupable forcément coupable c'est que le
président m'a sollicité beaucoup au
cours des réunions que nous faisions
dans le salon vert j'étais en face de
lui il me donnait la parole en premier
j'intervenais la cada prophète
débriefing de la situation je ne peux
pas prendre de notes autour de la table
tout le monde intervenait le soir même
j'avais un coup de fil du président à
22h30 c'était donc obligés de les faire
un compte rendu tout ce que j'ai dit que
seule façon pour moi de lui faire un
prétendu fidèle et un point c'était
évidemment vous faire des
enregistrements jeu n'a pas pu
travailler autrement
donc j'avais une obligation de résultat
pas une obligation de moyens les moyens
de regarder donc personne n'aurait
jamais su que j'ai enregistré la réunion
que j'ai d'ailleurs jamais utilisé fait
paraître deux livres lorsque à
l'enregistrement m'a été volé donc avec
inventé évidemment de me nuire et de
faire croire tout autre chose que la
réalité la réalité c'est que je le
faisais pour le travail parce que
j'étais payé quant à la personne qui a
dérobé ces enregistrements le circuit
parle que de ça c'est fait la
manipulation qui a été montée j'ai des
traiteurs des intervenants de ce qu'ils
ont fait les voies par lesquelles s'est
passé le site atlantico le cadre et
voilà c'est ça
[Musique]
je n'ai pas lu je ne vais pas lui pour
préserver
pour préserver l'avenir tout simplement
quand on écrit 700 pages sur son père
même pour en dire parfois du mal
c'est qu'il ya des sentiments disons
ambivalent et complexe voilà tout le
monde décrit paralyse comme ça sur
superman l'appel
[Musique]